MAKING US NUMBER ONE LAST
WEEKEND.
FIRST NOW MY OPENING STATEMENT.
IT'S COME TO THIS?
NO MORE CIVIL DISCOURSE?
WHAT HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY
TODAY IS BEYOND ANYTHING WE HAVE
EVER SEEN IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
POLITICAL DEBATE AT THE VERY
HEART OF THE FOUNDING OF THIS
COUNTRY HAS DEINVOLVED INTO
POLITICAL HARASSMENT AND
OUTRIGHT POLITICAL ABUSE.
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS, THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY, ONE
OF THE MOST OF PRESTIGIOUS JOBS
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., OUT TO
DINNER, PLACES HER ORDER AND IS
THEN TOLD TO LEAVE BY THE OWNER
BECAUSE SHE WORKS FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SARAH QUIETLY LEAVES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN THIS WEEK WAS LITERALLY
SCREAMED AND HECKLED OUT OF A
RESTAURANT WHILE EATING HER
DINNER.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE BEING
HARASSED ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
BY A HYSTERICAL LEFT UNWILLING
TO ACCEPT THE DECISION AND THE
WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO
PUT DONALD TRUMP IN OFFICE.
THESE UNHINGED LEFTISTS ARE
NORMALIZING OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR
WHICH IS ONLY GETTING WORSE.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
ONCE THE DEMOCRATS 24-7
COLLUSION NONSENSE FIZZLED,
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION OTHER THAN CORRUPTION
ON THE PART OF THE TOP LEVEL OF
THE FBI AND DOJ TO FRAME DONALD
TRUMP, THE LEFT NEEDED A NEW
ISSUE, A NEW DEFLECTION TO SOME
OTHER MADE-UP WRONGDOING ON THE
PART OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT COULD WE ACCUSE HIM OF?
WHAT CAN WE BLAME HIM FOR NOW?
THEY THEN DEFLECT TO THE
INHUMANE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER.
NOW, I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
I HAVE SPENT MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE FIGHTING FOR CHILDREN,
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED AND INJURED AND
HARMED.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
HEARTBREAKING THAN CHILDREN
BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
THE FAMILY COURT SEPARATES
PARENTS FROM THEIR CHILDREN
EVERY DAY, AND CRIMINAL JUDGES
SEPARATE PARENTS FROM THEIR
CHILDREN AND EVERY DAY CHILDREN
ARE PLACED IN FOSTER CARE.
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYONE ON
THE LEFT COMPLAIN.
FOR THOSE OF YOU SO BLIND BY
TRUMP HATRED.
THERE ARE LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY.
A PRIMER.
WHEN YOU CROSS THE BORDER INTO
THE UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY,
EXPECT TO BE ARRESTED.
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
COME HERE.
WE DID NOT INVITE YOU HERE.
AND YOU CANNOT STAY HERE.
BUT ON YOUR WAY OUT, YOU CAN
THANK BILL CLINTON AND HIS
FLORES SETTLEMENT THAT REQUIRES
CHILDREN BE TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEIR PARENTS WITHIN 20 DAYS OF
CROSSING THE BORDER.
AND YOU CAN ALSO THANK PRESIDENT
BUSH AND OBAMA FOR SIGNING INTO
LAW THAT CHILDREN CANNOT BE
DETAINED AT THE BORDER LONGER
THAN 20 DAYS UNDER THE
TRAFFICKING PROTECTION ACT.
NOW EVERYONE WANTS TO GO AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CREATED.
GEORGE BUSH DID NOTHING ABOUT
IT.
BARACK OBAMA DID NOTHING BY THE.
AND LAURA BUSH WE HAVEN'T SEEN
YOU FOR A WHILE.
THANKS FOR ENTERING THE FRAY AND
CALLING THE REMOVAL OF CHILDREN
TRUE AND INHUMANE.
WHY DIDN'T YOU JUST ROLL OVER
ONE NIGHT AND TELL YOUR HUSBAND
THE PRESIDENT THAT HIS ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY WAS CRUEL AND
INHUMANE?
THE LEFT JUST DOESN'T CARE WHAT
THE FACTS ARE.
POLITICIANS ARE WILLING TO STAND
UP AND TOTALLY CONTRADICT
THEMSELVES IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
CREATE POLITICAL CHAOS, HATRED
AND ABUSE.
STENY HOYER, THE MOST OF
SENIOR-HANGING DEMOCRAT IN
CONGRESS -- SENIOR-RANKING
LAWYER SAYS THIS.
>> HE'S TAKING INFANT CHILDREN
HOSTAGE.
WRENCHING THEM FROM THE ARMS OF
THEIR PARENTS.
TRAUMATIZING THEM PERHAPS FOR
LIFE.
JUDGE JEANINE: STENY, YOU HAVE
BEEN IN CONGRESS FOR 37 YEARS.
YOU SAID NOTHING DURING THE
CLINTON, BUSH OR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, AND NOW YOU ARE
WORRIED?
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS SAYS THIS.
>> WE I AM PRISONED THEM.
WE PUT THEM BEHIND BARBED WIRES.
JUDGE JEANINE: KAMALA, WHEN YOU
WERE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
CALIFORNIA, OVER ONE MILLION
PEOPLE WERE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN.
THE SEPARATING OF CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES ONLY HURTS IF
DONALD TRUMP IS PRESIDENT?
PETER FONDA SAYS WE SHOULD RIP
THE PRESIDENT'S SON FROM HIS
MOTHER'S ARMS AND PUT HIM IN A
CAGE WITH PEDOPHILES.
PETER WHY DON'T YOU GET ON YOUR
MOTORCYCLE AND TAKE A RIDE OFF
THE PLANET.
J-LO SAYS THIS CHILD IS
SEPARATED FROM HER PARENTS IN
MOSUL BY ISIS.
EVEN "TIME" MAGAZINE IS SO BLIND
THAT THEY IGNORE ALL
JOURNALISTIC STANDARD TO TRASH
DONALD TRUMP.
THE CHILD DEPICTED HERE ANOTHER
COVER WAS NOT SEPARATED FROM HER
MOTHER.
IN FACT THE CHILD HERE WAS TAKEN
BY THE MOTHER WITHOUT THE
FATHER'S PERMISSION OR KNOWLEDGE
OR CONSENT FROM HER HOME
COUNTRY.
AND THIS MOTHER BY THE WAY HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN DEPORTED.
WE CANNOT ALLOW OUR COUNTRY TO
BE OVERRUN BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THE ON RESOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM IS TO BUILD THE WALL.
AMNESTY DOES NOTHING BUT CREATE
AN INCENTIVE FOR ADDITIONAL
CROSSING BILE ILLEGALS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SIMPLY LOOKING
FOR AN ISSUE FOR THE 2018
MID-TERMS.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO LIE, CREATE
FALSE IMAGES AND A MOVEMENT TO
INTIMIDATE TRUMP SUPPORTERS THEY
WILL STOP AT NOTHING.
WE ARE IN A DANGEROUS PLACE
RIGHT NOW.
HATE IS HATE.
HATE LEAD TO HARASSMENT AND
ABUSE.
AND THAT ABUSE LEADS TO
VIOLENCE.
AND THAT VIOLENCE LEADS TO
RETALIATION.
ANY THREAT OF VIOLENCE THAT CON
INJURES UP A VISUAL OF VIOLENCE
IS MORE DANGEROUS THAN JUST
HAVING DIFFERENT POLITICAL
VIEWS.
WE ARE A VERY SHORT DISTANCE
FROM THOSE WILLING TO CROSS THE
LINE OF POLITICAL DEBATE TO
THOSE WILLING TO CROSS THE LINE